bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 18 septembre
depuis 70 jours maintenant nos amis
jean-jacques le garrec irlande madura
sont détenus par les rebelles sur l'île
de jolo
avec eux il ya seize autres otages
philippins et malaisiens il serait
toujours vivant avec les rebelles
réfugiés dans les monts volcaniques pour
faire face l'offensive militaire des
troupes de manif tentative de coup
d'état à abidjan ce soir le calme est
revenu et le général robert gueï est
toujours en place multiples
protestations des restaurateurs français
contre la tva imposée aux métiers de
l'hôtellerie campagne du référendum pour
le quinquennat six jours avant la
consultation ce soir le choix du front
national et de son président monsieur
jean marie le pen
une bien belle journée française aux
jeux olympiques six médailles de plus
dont une en or
enfin la sortie du dernier album de
bjork celle qui triomphe au cinéma à
cannes avec dancer in the dark
cette part de ses goûts et de ses
différences en exclusivité à olivier
dénoue st pas question de cesser le feu
sur l'île de jolo
le président philippin joseph estrada
l'a répété au troisième jour de
l'offensive de son armée contre les
rebelles qui détiennent sur cette île 18
otages dont jean-jacques le garrec qui
est roland madura et puis sur une île
voisine un ressortissant américain
quatre mille soldats sont déployés à
bruxelles ce matin le ministre français
des affaires étrangères hubert védrine
réaffirmait que les autorités
philippines devait tout faire pour
éviter que les actions menées portent
atteinte à la sécurité des otages ceci
serait avec les ravisseurs dans une zone
de mont volcanique quasi inexpugnable
sur cette île de jolo commentaires
bernard lebrun
la rotation des c130 philippa milieu de
journée à paris soirée à ambohimanga au
troisième jour de l'offensive l'armée et
évacuer les civils de l'île de jolo où
résident et quatre cent mille habitants
ils sont plusieurs centaines parfois
aisée parfois simples travailleurs sur
ville et non résidents tous disent que
le port de jeu dans le port de gelos la
situation est calme et que les
militaires tiennent la ville mais qu'à
l'intérieur de l'île il y à des
bombardements nouveau bilan officiel qui
fait état ce soir d'une seule victime de
quatre blessés parmi les civils
quatre mille soldats appuyés par
l'aviation la marine participent à
l'offensive dirigé par cet homme plongé
dans ses cartes
le général angelo reyes objectif jaune
l'une des sept mille îles du pays
minuscule repaires des rebelles dix fois
plus petite que la corse 60 km de long
par 20 de large selon nos informations
les ravisseurs auraient quitté samedi le
camp de talent ipao pour se cacher au
nord en zone montagneuse avec leurs
otages dont nos deux confrères
jean-jacques le garrec et roland madura
sur ces images de la télévision
philippine qui a pu suivre l'hélicoptère
du général on aperçoit très bien le
relief volcanique et accidentées de
jolis ce que l'on ne voit pas sous la
jungle ce sont les centaines de galeries
creusées par les japonais durant la
dernière guerre et que connaissent
parfaitement les rebelles d'abou sayyaf
pour libérer les philippines les troupes
américaines du général macarthur ont
combattu durant 11 mois et c'est au
lance-flammes qu'il déloge r les soldats
japonais
dans ses galeries souterraines étaient
réputés un preneur alors le commandant
robot le sait le temps joue pour lui ce
n'est certes pas en une semaine que le
fort
dans estrada maîtriseront jaune pour
autant il n'y aura pas de trêve man il a
répété aujourd'hui
l'offensive se poursuivre sans plus de
négociations bonne nouvelle en revanche
puisque deux volontaires de
l'organisation humanitaire action contre
la faim une française et un britannique
avaient été enlevés à la fin du mois de
juillet dernier à mogadiscio en somalie
ont été libérés ce matin l'organisation
acf salue la mobilisation des nouveaux
dirigeants se magne en côte d'ivoire une
élection présidentielle est prévue pour
le 22 octobre prochain la compagnie
toral n'est pas de tout repos
le général robert gueï arrivée au
pouvoir le 24 décembre 99 par un coup
d'état a bien failli être à son tour
victime d'opposants son palais
présidentiel a été attaqué une vingtaine
de membres de sa garde rapprochée ont
été arrêtés reportage de nos
correspondants permanents abidjan eric
monier hergé motte l' attaque avec pour
cible la résidence privée du général
robert gueï une maison ouverte aux
journalistes ce matin pour qu'ils
constatent eux mêmes l'ampleur des
dégâts impacts de balles sur la façade
et les véhicules du cortège présidentiel
blindés légers immobilisé dans un mur
selon le pouvoir militaire ivoirien une
vingtaine d'assaillants aurait donné
l'assaut vers une heure du matin
pénétrant dans l'enceinte avant d'y être
définitivement chassé deux heures plus
tard par la garde rapprochée du chef de
l'état et le concours de renforts
notamment de la gendarmerie le coup de
force aurait fait deux morts chez les
loyalistes
pas d'information en revanche sur les
motivations des assaillants ni sur
l'identité des quelques suspects arrêtés
dans un périmètre proche du lieu de
l'attentât
vers 11 heures un robert gueï calme et
on civile répondaient à la presse sans
beaucoup plus de précision peut-on par
exemple parlé d'attentât contre sa
personne et a donné que je n'ai pas
assisté à la préparation
il me sera difficile de donner un doute
ce que disaient c'est qu'il ya eu des
rumeurs qui ont été confirmés à vous de
choisir le moyen gâte
dans l'entourage du général pourtant ce
matin on ne se privait pas d'évoquer des
commanditaires tapis dans l'ombre dans
leur villa abidjanaise et beaucoup de
reconnaître dans ce portrait alassane
ouattara l'ancien premier ministre
d'houphouët wayne et ses partisans des
partisans qui se relaient devant la
demeure de leur leader depuis 48 heures
redoutant son arrestation à nouveau les
armes ont parlé dans les rues d'abidjan
une bien curieuse manière de se préparer
à l'élection présidentielle toujours
prévu le 22 octobre prochain comme l'ont
confirmé les militaires une élection à
laquelle robert gueï et alassane
ouattara sont tous deux candidats la
suite de la détente entre la corée du
nord et la corée du sud détente entamée
en juin par une rencontre entre les
dirigeants des deux parties de ce pays
le président sud coréen ce matin
solennellement ouvert le chantier d'un
futur chemin de fer qui reliera bientôt
la corée du nord à la corée du sud en
irlande du nord deux explosions ont eu
lieu l'une non loin de belfast à bangor
une camionnette piégée a fait un blessé
et puis l'année dernière une bombe a
détruit des bureaux d'une association
protestante loyaliste
cette fois dans le centre ville de
belfast hier de nouveau dans deux
territoires autonomes palestiniens de
gaza des jeunes palestiniens se sont
affrontés avec les forces israéliennes
près de la colonie juive de netzarim ces
incidents marqué le 18e anniversaire du
massacre de réfugiés palestiniens dans
les camps de sabra et chatila au liban
massacres perpétrés par des phalangistes
libanais avec la complicité passive des
forces israéliennes des musulmans des
chrétiens ont été tués par milliers
dix-huit ans après c'est un lieu de
souvenir qui n'a guère changé
voyez le reportage de bernard lebrun et
pascal car les embarras de la capitale
n'épargne aucun quartier papus le centre
que l'entrée du souk de chhattisgarh aux
abords du camp flotte le drapeau d'amal
la milice
yp libanaise qui depuis vingt ans en
cercle et s'unit palestiniens deuxième
cercle plus discret celui tenu par
l'armée qui patrouille sans relâche sur
le marché l'avenue s'appelle la rue du
massacre
bordet des vestiges de l'ancien camp pad
étages aux maisons aux toits de tôle non
fixée c'était la règle quand les
palestiniens s'installèrent
provisoirement en 1948
un provisoire qui dure depuis 52 ans
seul terrain vague de chatila un
cimetière l'exil et la négation du
souvenir s'ils sont enterrés les 3500
martyrs des camps de sabra et chatila
ils ont été massacrés par les miliciens
phalangistes dans cette fosse commune
il y à des chrétiens et des musulmans
tous palestiniens par les pro israéliens
en septembre 1981 le mans d'un cimetière
pas même signaler où jouent les enfants
un terrain vague sans plaque du monument
entouré de ruines officiellement le
massacre a fait 2000 victimes et ici
comme ailleurs les statistiques sont un
enjeu politique
exemple impossible aujourd'hui de
connaître le nombre exact de réfugiés
palestiniens
deux cent mille selon l'unrwa l'agencé
de l'onu 400 mille selon les libanais
qui les exècre pour raisons économiques
afin d'éviter leur enracinement le liban
ont fait des réfugiés des non citoyens
ni droit de vote ni droit au travail on
peut pas continuer comme ça les
palestiniens n'ont pas des droits civils
ils sont même capables d'influencer la
situation générale économique et
politique des palestiniens pour le web
du tout chez eux et chaude ni les
palestiniens ni les libanais jusqu'à
maintenant n'ont pas réussi à exercer
des pressions subies cela allait
convaincre finir avec leur entêtement
sur le fût de loi de l'étude
loin de gaza et jéricho très loin des
débats politiques de yasser arafat trois
millions et demi de palestiniens au
moyen-orient attente dans l'oubli et la
misère l'heure du retour à chatila dans
ce camp provisoire devenue ville en un
demi-siècle d'exil un slogan gronde
comme une menace pas de retour
pas de paix pas de paix durable au moyen
orient
au pérou de la décision du président
alberto fujimori de provoquer de
nouvelles élections présidentielles et
de ne pas se représenter a été saluée
avec soulagement y compris dans nombre
de pays étrangers la récente élection
présidentielle péruvienne avait il est
vrai été largement entachée
d'irrégularités les cuisiniers les
restaurateurs français se sont à leur
tour rappelé au bon souvenir de lionel
jospin ça fait longtemps qu'on leur
promet des baisses de charges
il demande à obtenir une tva de 5 5% au
lieu de 19 6 comme c'est le cas pour les
restaurants de vente à emporter des
manifestations tu dû à montpellier dans
la manche mais également à toulouse
lille albi notamment à poitiers les
restaurateurs se sont rassemblés devant
la préfecture
philippe ritaine et christophe devals
embrasse en ont profité pour interroger
un restaurateur traditionnelle et
puissant voisin
son voisin qui vient d'ouvrir une
boutique de sandwichs ils renoncent à
leur droit de vote
des restaurateurs des cafetiers les
professionnels de l'hôtellerie manifeste
il ne supporte plus la pression fiscale
le geste est fort symbolique la rupture
nous ramassons des cartes d'électeur
pour les rendre à monsieur le préfet est
ce que nous nous battrons ça ne sert à
rien nous sommes jamais écoutés donc on
rend nos cartes d'électeur autant faire
ce qu'ils réclament c'est cette baisse
de la tva 5% et demi au lieu de 19,6 il
explique qu'il en va de l'avenir de la
profession dans ce restaurant de
poitiers par exemple sur un menu à 100
francs 40 partant charges salaires taxe
trop lourd on aurait bien besoin de main
d'oeuvre supplémentaire mais il faudrait
un coup de pouce baisse de la tva ça
signifie que moi aujourd'hui j'ai neuf
salariés j'ai quatre apprentis bas
demain je suis prêt à embaucher deux ou
trois personnes en fonction de
l'économie que je vais pouvoir avoir sur
ma tv à et augmenter les salaires de mai
on voyait juste en face on vend des
sandwichs de la nourriture à emporter
la nuance est de taille la législation
bien différent
vous avez le tva combien vous monsieur
moi je suis à 5,5 actuellement
si je devais passer à 19,6 comme les
restaurateurs le constructeur a tout de
suite parce que je suis un ancien
restaurateur je vais le tester avant et
puis j'ai tout abandonné à cause de la
tva qui est vraiment un renvoi pour nous
pour leur profession c'est précisément
ce cas de figure que redoutent les
restaurateurs il estime en revanche que
cette baisse de tva pourrait créer 150 à
200 mille emplois c'est également pour
une baisse de la tva une réduction de
leurs charges que les artisans des auto
écoles ont défilé dans plusieurs villes
de france brest quimper tours valence
programme également qu'en hébreu
limoges ici nous sommes à bordeaux et
ensuite on verra défiler à rodez à paris
et plusieurs centaines de voitures qui
ont occupé les rues du centre de la
capitale
les fédérations de cheminots cgt cfdt fo
et autonome viennent de déposer un
préavis de grève pour le 28 septembre
prochain ils réclament la réouverture de
négociations salariales
a la sncf les modalités de la
privatisation du groupe électronique
thomson multimédia ayant été précisés
les particuliers peuvent dès maintenant
réserver des actions on annonce de
bonnes affaires y compris pour l'état
qui pourrait récolter 10 milliards de
francs environ
et pourtant thomson multimédia fut jadis
considéré comme sans intérêt
commentaires david boeri devant les
caméras et photographes
le pdg de thomson multimédia a de quoi
sourire aujourd'hui son groupe de près
de cent milliards de francs la bourse de
paris
rien à voir avec le thomson de 1996 qui
devait être cédée au groupe coréen
daewoo m comme seuls multimédia je le
répète ça vaut un franc symbolique
après recapitalisation parce que dans
l'état actuel des choses ça me rend rien
ça vaut des dettes
ça vaut 14 milliards de dette la formule
fait descendre les salariés de thomson
dans la rue le débat devient politique
à gauche les socialistes à l'heure dans
l'opposition refusent toute idée
privatisation nous ne sommes pas pour la
privatisation
nous nous pensons que le groupe doit
rester public qu'on doit leur équilibre
et il en prend le chemin
pour le rééquilibrer le gouvernement
jospin remet 11 milliards de francs dans
le groupe en décembre 97
la promesse est tenue mais thomson ne
restera pas publique
aujourd'hui l'état ne détient plus que
35% du capital
les marchés financiers a
le 10 en moins d'un an le cours de
l'action a déjà été multiplié par six
c'est d'affaires intéressant pour les
particuliers d'avoir dû thomson
multimédia
thomson multimédia est le quatrième
constructeur d'électronique grand public
dans le monde et cette industrie est à
l'aube d'un bouleversement qu'elle n'a
jamais connu depuis 20 ans grâce au tout
numérique
depuis le début de l'année le chiffre
d'affaires a progressé de 45% en misant
sur les nouvelles technologies
le groupe est en passe de redevenir le
fleuron de l'électronique française
il y aura trois lys trois candidats au
deuxième tour des élections municipales
d'ajaccio mais le bonapartiste marc marc
cherry mais ressortant à une nette
avance sur son ancien ami josé ross ce
dernier aura bien besoin des voix
nationalistes favorables aux accords de
matignon
s'il veut l'emporter dimanche prochain
reportage arnaud boutet et philippe
chasselas
les bonapartistes chante l'ajaccienne et
vénère leur maire sortant marc marc
angeli
aujourd'hui la ville de napoléon a
retrouvé son calme
les candidats analyse les résultats pour
la liste arrivée en tête qui s'opposent
aux accords de matignon
ce vote a été un réflexe république
tahar flex républicain de gens dit quand
été frustré de ne pas avoir été
interrogés et qu'ils pensent que peut
être une évolution institutionnelle voir
constitutionnel pourrait être une
antichambre de l'indépendance n'ont
manifestement la majeure partie de la
course avec seulement 21 % des voix josé
rossi accuse le coup lui qui soutient le
plan jospin considère que les ajacciens
entend partie sanctionner la réforme
mais aujourd'hui il se fixe un seul
objectif rattraper son retard par le
report des voix au second tour trois
listes au lieu de huit ça change
complètement la donne et je suis second
et j'espère être la force alternative
par rapport au maire sortant
problème les nationalistes qui ne
franchissent pas la barre reste très
discret sur les consignes de vote
ailleurs la pêche aux voix déjà commencé
cet après midi simon renucci était
absent de sa permanence le pédiatre
ajacciens qui sera au second tour
négocier avec la liste communiste
éliminé dimanche soir enfin il y a les
abstentionnistes 10000 ajacciens qui
toute la semaine seront traqués puis
harcelés par les trois équipes de
campagne leur vote peut encore tout
changer
il y aura aussi dimanche prochain le
référendum bonsoir monsieur le pen donc
parler des choix du front national j'ai
vu une petite affichette le conte kenna
bon ça ne formule pas très très élégant
mais pourquoi vous traitez avec
désinvolture ce sont les jeunes du front
national de la jeunesse qui ont voulu
mettre un peu de piment un peu d'humour
dans une campagne qui est assez
tristounette il faut bien le dire
alors pourquoi vous dites non pour
beaucoup de raisons je dirais que la
première pour laquelle je dis non c'est
que je suis assez fâché que le président
chirac est fixée le josé référendum
le jour de notre fête des bleu blanc
rouge avec le traditionnel annuel et ce
qui m' évidemment ne nous aide pas bah
oui je me rends bien servi tant que
jusqu'à 20 heures
les médias n'ont pas le droit de parler
des activités politiques
j'espère qu'elle s'arrêtera t pour la
faible tout à fait alors vous dit non
parce qu'au fond c'est ce formidable
comme tout le monde dit oui je dirai
dans l'est dans les grands partis où
c'est plus facile pour vous dire non non
non c'est plus raisonnée que ça quand
même
nous disons non pour plusieurs raisons
la première qui est lié directement à la
question qui est posée c'est que nous ne
sommes pas d'accord pour réduire la
durée du mandat du président pourquoi ce
qui est moderne tout le monde le fait
tous les nantis tous les pays le font ne
le crois pas et on a en a déclaré par
exemple que nous voulions nous
rapprocher des pays européens sur 15
pays européens y en a dix qui ont des
durées de deux chefs de l'état qui sont
égales ou plus le rouge
il ya cette monarchie ce sont des cet
avis c'est un peu particulier vous
n'êtes pas pour le roi quand même si mal
problème c'est qu'on nous dit il faut
nous rapprocher des pays européens si
cette mandat à vie et y en a trois qui
sont et cela parle de gens qui sont élus
et présidents des états unis ces quatre
ans oui je crois pas du tout à cet
argument basque ainsi chez moderne de
passer de sept à cinq ans c'est encore
plus moderne de passer de cinq à trois
ans hans fehr vinci en campagne
électorale permanente
non je crois que c'est une des commandes
et des jeunes des prérogatives du
président qui dans notre constitution
lui donne ce poids parce qu'il y ait qui
lui permet d'être arbitre est garant de
l'unité nationale surtout à un moment il
faut le dire
oula l'état est menacé par le terrorisme
et la séparatisme et où la nation est
menacée par lettre
souveraineté massif qui sont concédés à
l'europe de bruxelles
quand même un président fort alors
pourtant monsieur le pen vous n'êtes pas
très favorable à la cohabitation on dit
que le quinquennat réduira les chances
ou leiris de la cohabitation je ne crois
pas du tout puisque toute une série de
comment dirais-je de situations
permettent de refaire la cohabitation la
démission du président sa disparition la
dissolution voire même le jour où les
deux consultations seraient parallèle
quelqu'un vote à la fois pour un parti
pour les élections et pour un président
d'un autre l'autre couleur vous évoquez
la dissolution en fait quand même le
président gardera un droit majeur celui
de dissoudre brouillon il a quatre
droits particuliers il a en effet il est
élu au suffrage universel
il a une durée supérieure à celle des
députés il a le droit de dissolution et
il a les pouvoirs spéciaux de l'article
or on lui enlève une partie statut que
si vous voulez comme l'italie il lui
reste les plus forts comme une table
kataka pied au dot on couperait de
centimètres sur un pied il ya des traits
rien qui ça me plaît bien table bancale
selon les très fier qu'il irait bien je
ne souhaite pas de constitution soit par
calvet ça c'est la première raison mais
il y en a une autre c'est que on nous
avait promis ce schéma nous avait promis
pendant sa campagne présidentielle qu'il
interrogerait les français par
référendum sur au moins trois sujets
l'euro le amsterdam et l'éducation et
n'a pas tenu ses promesses et les
français souhaiteraient être un terreau
lieu c'est pour ça qu'ils se
désintéressent est au fond il n'y a pas
une grosse tradition référendaire en
france est-ce qu'au fond de la banlieue
parce que le pouvoir n'a jamais souhaité
le pouvoir souhaite la délégation et il
souhaite en profiter au maximum le seul
référendum ou des français se révolter
cent soixante deux pour de gaulle
oui c'est à peu près les fantômes plus
vaste friche sommes tout de même sur la
constitution ouais où j'ai voté
d'ailleurs oui à la gombe site lille au
tarif de voter oui de temps à temps
absolument j'ai voté pour la
constitution parce qu'elle me paraissait
meilleure que celle de la quatrième
république elle donnait à l'état une
stabilité qui lui manquait préalablement
mai
je crois que supprimer ou réduire cette
prérogative
c'est ce serait nuire à l' équilibre des
pouvoirs mais je crois surtout que ils
les français voudraient répondre à des
questions et moi je leur demande de
répondre aux questions qu'on leur a pas
posé tout ce qui touche à l'immigration
à la sécurité au chômage aux fiscalisme
et c est bien ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord avec le gouvernement socialo
communistes ils ont la possibilité de
dire non et ils doivent le dire
au moins ça animera un peu la
consultation merci monsieur le plein il
y a beaucoup plus que de l'amertume et
de la tristesse chez les
sapeurs-pompiers engagés en corse dans
les multiples lutte contre les incendies
le plus souvent criminels
hier c'est un jeune militaire 22 ans de
la sécurité civile qui est mort sept
autres pompiers ont été blessés dont
quatre grièvement sur un col de pal hk
en balagne en haute corse
reportage olivier théron et à répondre à
la colère et l'émotion les hommes de la
sécurité civile et les pompiers de corse
se sont recueillis devant le cercueil de
nicholas kamm au 23 ans nord dans les
flammes dans ces flammes criminels qui
ont ravagé l'accord cet été le corps du
jeune appelé un parti vers auxerre pour
y être enterré un mort deux blessés dans
un état critique
quatre hommes encore hospitalisés tout
ça par la volonté criminelle
d'incendiaires plonge la corse dans la
colère
la mort d'un jeune pompier qui faisait
son service militaire continental qui
vient défendre une terre la nôtre qui
est enseignée par les nôtres c'est un
sentiment d'horreur que ne pourra voir
et je dis que trop c'est trop
au tour plus les gens encore si 90 % des
incendies sont d'origine criminelle
en corse ils correspondent souvent à des
terres à verger ou des terrains de
chasse
les zones à risque sont connus mais il y
a peu d'arrestations et encore plus
rarement de procès manque de preuves et
surtout de témoignages moi je voudrais
peut-être encourager les personnes qui
ont pu être témoins de ces faits de
parler et de dire aux services bancaires
notamment à la gendarmerie
ce 15 août en attendant la bonne volonté
des témoins il reste l'anc est sur le
terrain les gendarmes cet après-midi ont
ratissé les restes du maquis brûlés à la
recherche d'un indice qui pourrait
trahir l'incendiaire un travail qui
malheureusement n'a donné aucun résultat
à nanterre au procès devant un tribunal
correctionnel du financement occulte du
rpr un ancien et du gaulliste maire de
maurepas dans les yvelines qui figure
parmi les accusés a reconnu avoir touché
plus de 400 mille francs grâce à des
fausses factures
l'argent aurait permis de financer sa
campagne et orale selon l'accusation
aujourd'hui l'association des paralysés
de france apf monette une série
d'actions spectaculaires pour obtenir
enfin un meilleur accès aux transports
en commun
à paris et dans 28 villes des personnes
handicapées accompagnées de bénévoles
ont démontré en tentant d'accéder à des
bus des tramways des métros que
décidément nous avions beaucoup de
progrès à faire pour leur faciliter leur
vie quotidienne les ratés p certes fait
des efforts mais c'est pas le cas de la
sncf
après un an d'existence le rer eole
ignore presque totalement les handicapés
une seule gare à noisy le sec est équipé
reportages démonstrations marque
maisonneuve claude bernier vincent
ferreira et le rer tout neuf n'est pas
prévu pour les handicapés mais comme le
dit si bien gladys le chauffard qui l'a
clouée dans un fauteuil il y à 16 ans
ça n'était pas prévu non plus
alors elles manifestent pour réclamer
son droit à circuler librement comme les
valides on vit dans des galères il ya
des lois qui existent pour pour rendre
compliqué à 3 6 8 et 6 passes et donc
monuments historiques la gare de pantin
est ainsi classé impossible de
réaménager d'où la colère des paralysés
de france
nous adressons un carton rouge à la sncf
qui n'a réussi qu'à remettre en place
des chaises à porteur avec comme porteur
des emplois jeunes gladys obligé de
demander de l'aide
alors que le coût de la construction de
deux marches est identique à celui
imminent mais ça n'était pas prévu
m
la gare n'est pas aménagé le train non
plus le parcours du combattant continue
demander de l'aide
encore et encore complètement voilà et
hall a à peine plus d'un an et 35 % de
ceux qui vivent en ile de france ont une
mobilité réduite
impossible de sortir non la gare de
noisy le sec est la seule à être aménagé
pour la circulation en fauteuil roulant
pourtant il a fallu attendre dix minutes
et demandé à un employé de bien vouloir
ouvrir la grille
par exemple en ile de france on doit
avoir sur 380 garde 17 gars qui sont aux
normes actuelles pour les handicapés
selon la sncf le coût de transformation
des gares serait trop élevé pour la
collectivité
très belle journée française à sydney
aux jeux olympiques six médailles d'un
coup les félicitations de jacques chirac
et lionel jospin et une deuxième place
au classement total pour la france
derrière les etats unis 12 médailles
jusqu'à présent quatre d'or six d'argent
et deux de bronze c'est pas fini nous en
distingueront quelques-unes en cyclisme
vous voyez marion clignet elle aborde
avec sur la deuxième place
et puis aux tirs l'argent également pour
delphine racinet et puis surtout une
magistrale démonstration de l'équipe de
france de canoë-kayak tony estanguet a
remporté l'or en canoë monoplace et ce
quatre ans après la médaille de bronze
de son propre frère dans cette même
discipline dans la famille on est donc
très sourire commentaires alexandre car
un grand sourire celui d'un gamin
heureux à qui l'on a offert le plus beau
des cadeaux
à 22 ans tony estanguet est devenu
aujourd'hui champion olympique de slalom
en canoë
il a réalisé un rêve que son frère avait
fait avant lui mais en 96 à atlanta
l'autre estanguet patrice n'avait
décroché que la médaille de bronze
voir ces petits bouts de métal pour les
bons conseils
c'est un bon moment et c'est vrai que
c'est le soulagement parce que parce que
vraiment j'y croyais mais je pensais que
ce serait très difficile
et bien voila quoi ça y était la mienne
toujours en slalom mais cette fois en
kayak féminin
les françaises ont prouvé qu'elle était
à l'aise dans le bain olympique
brigitte guibal a raté de peu la
première marche du podium mais une
médaille d'argent
c'est plus qu'il n'en fallait pour faire
son bonheur avec sin elle découvre ses
premiers jeux et la bonne ambiance des
olympiens attendez pas à voir autant de
français
c'est vrai que ça nous a énormément
convoi le 5 points qui font les
australiens qu'un australien fait c'est
vrai que ça nous aiderait moi ça m'a
porté sur les demandes génial médaille
de bronze
anne-lise bardaine était il ya encore
peu que remplaçant la titulaire est
tombé malade
alors quand le sort s'en mêle trois
médailles en un jour pour le canoë kayak
s'est déjà autant que durant les jeux
d'atlanta
c'est dire si à l'avenir on ne peut
avoir que de bonnes surprises
elle a au point où nous en sommes
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas d'or les
médailles serait presque décevante pour
les français ainsi chez les escrimeurs
la défaite en finale du tournoi et peu à
laisser quelques regrets mais il ya
quand même une belle deuxième place
commentaires julien beaumont
inconsolable hugues obry
c'est la seconde finale qu'il perd en
trois jours et ça fait beaucoup d'échecs
pour un seul homme pour sa première
participation aux jo il se voyait déjà
couverts d'or mais en individuel il n'a
récolté que l'argent une bonne raison de
mettre le paquet en équipe une victoire
qu'il aurait voulu offrir à eric srecki
eric l'un des autres membres du trio
l'homme qui lui a tant appris mais dans
le point décisif celui qui doit désigner
un vainqueur aubry c'est cool face à son
adversaire italien des italiens qui
n'ont jamais mené au score mais qui
excelle dans l'art de la provocation
eric srecki ici à droite participé à sa
dernière compétition sans amertume ni
regret il rate lors mines a aucun doute
sur sa succession
personne n'est irremplaçable il ya tout
ce qu'il faut dans cette équipe pour
pour assumer la relève et sans oublier
tous les copains l'insep sous les toits
par les groupes qui nous ont aidés tout
l'été à nous préparer
il ya là dedans leur champion sur le
podium
le trio three qui dit martine aubry à la
tête des mauvais jours
à trop rêver d'or on en vient parfois
oublier que l'argent c'est aussi une
médaille et en natation le mérite des
nageurs de ciney de quelque nationalité
qu'ils soient est grand mais il serait
parait-il bien aidé par les conditions
offertes dans la piscine olympique de
très nombreux records du monde ont déjà
été amélioré dans des premières journées
de compétition
mais la surprise et la déception pour
les australiens est venue de la victoire
du néerlandais pieter van den hoogenband
devançant le nageur prodige australien
ian thorpe l'exploit des uns étant à la
mesure de la qualité du bassin dit
explications florent gautreau et
philippe deslandes la torpille est battu
par un hollandais volant thorpe est allé
un peu moins vite que randa new girl
band qui a égalé le record du monde du
200 m encore une course d'anthologie
encore un temps canon depuis le début
des jeux huit records du monde ont été
battus dans la piscine olympique
les australiens l'ont rebaptisé paradis
de la natation les français plus mesurés
ont quand même profité du bassin pour
battre 4 records nationaux
j'attribue pas du tout un majeur de
qualité
agen patois l'accoutumée
elle est belle elle est chère et elle
est rapide construite pour les jo il ya
six ans elle a coûté 800 millions de
francs
il faut dire qu'on n'a pas hésité à
investir dans un équipement ultramoderne
dont le responsable n'est pas peu fier
un filtre à eau zone améliore la
visibilité et fait disparaître le goût
du chlore
la température est maintenue à 26° bref
plus de confort pour les nageurs et plus
de vitesse aussi car on a presque réussi
à éliminer les bagues grâce à de
nouvelles lignes d'eau du côté droit là
où les nageurs s'entraînent en ce moment
vous pouvez voir des ondulations sur
l'eau de l'autre côté il ya moins de
turbulences simple les vagues créées par
un nageur sont amortis et ainsi elle ne
gêne pas le concurrent de kilwa rasant
des flotteurs qui absorbe les chocs il
fallait y penser
et dans cette piscine pas vraiment comme
les autres il y a dix couloirs et non
pas 8 de chaque côté du bassin les deux
couloirs supplémentaires permettent à
l'eau de s'évacuer tranquillement au
lieu de revenir gêner les nageurs c'est
devenu psychologique
les nageurs se motive encore plus il y à
un public de connaisseurs si vous
additionnez le toucan comprenez pourquoi
il ya autant de records battus il ya
bien sûr le talent des nageurs
il y as peut-être ces fameuses
combinaisons en peau de requin il ya
encore ce fabuleux public australien qui
transforme le centre aquatique en
chaudron surchauffée
mais il ya aussi cette étonnante piscine
qui fait parler d'elle sans faire de
vagues
et pendant les épreuves la vigilance
anti dopage s'exerce mais de façon
parfois surprenante puisque l'équipe
d'haltérophilie roumaine exclu en
totalité dans un premier temps reste
maintenant à sydney la sanction était
annulé contre le paiement d'une amende
de 50 mille dollars américains
quatre athlètes romain restera donc à
signer commentaires julien riches
elle avoue mettre du coeur à l'ouvragé
la roumaine mario aura monté à nous ne
va terminer que huitième de sa
compétition d'haltérophilie loin du
podium et c'est tant mieux diront
certains histoire de ne pas rajouter de
l'huile sur le feu à la récente
polémique olympique car monter à nous a
failli ne pas participer à cette épreuve
le règlement de la fédération
internationale est très clair si en un
an 3 haltérophiles d'une même nation
sont convaincus de dopage c'est toute
l'équipe qui doit être exclu des
compétitions
le dernier cas positif a été révélée
hier exit donc l'équipe romaine une
fermeté appuyé par le comité
international olympique vous dire que
quoi qu'il arrive les haltérophiles
roumains sont bel et bien exclu et nous
leur demandons de quitter le village
olympique
tu mets tout sévère qu'il soit le
règlement frau fédération un repêchage
le versement d'une amende leur permet
d'engager malgré tout leurs athlètes
l'esprit olympique de sydney contre
quelques billets
soit vous payer une amende de 50 mille
dollars soit vous êtes privé de
compétition pour un an
si vous payez vous n'êtes plus exclu
trois cent cinquante mille francs et
tout redevient comme avant
face au dopage le comité international
olympique désiré davantage de
transparence davantage de fermeté le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
pour l'instant tout cela bien mal
commencé et puis le cycliste français
emmanuel magnien n'ira pas aux jeux
olympiques il avait été contrôlé positif
lors du dernier tour de france cycliste
le tribunal arbitral du sport viennent
le suspendre la six mois dont trois mois
ferme
emmanuel magne elle n'ira donc pas à
sydney on a appris en fin d'après midi
le décès du producteur d'émissions
télévisées gilbert carpentier
il était âgé de 81 ans il était
producteur avec son épouse marie
carpentier de très nombreuses émissions
de variétés ils avaient beaucoup
augmenté beaucoup et des artistes depuis
le rtf jusqu'à ces dernières années
alors ce soir à france 2 celles et ceux
qui ont eu le plaisir le bonheur de
travailler avec eux et nous avons une
pensée amicale émue pour eux maritime m
carpentier et puis le décès du comédien
chanteur armand mestral mort hier à
l'âge de 83 ans à paris et fut chanteur
dans des opérettes comédie musicale dans
les années 50
acteur de théâtre mais aussi de séries
télévisées il avait à peu près tout fait
dans ce métier
la sortie d'un nouvel album celui ci
s'il y est bio rck la chanteuse a
composé la musique originale du film
dancer in the dark de lars von triers
celui qui a obtenu la palme d'or cette
année à cannes
bjork avec aussi remporté le prix
d'interprétation féminine pour france 2
olivier les nous dit à kristof vignal
ont obtenu de la rencontrer à new york
york pour la première fois se racontent
la boîte un effet garé perdu dans
l'enfer de new york
bjork bikoum de l'avant-guerre musique
elle a passé trois années de sa vie a
composé la bande originale du film de
lars von trier dancer in the dark
je suis quelqu'un de très curieux
je suis attiré par les extrêmes les
choses impossibles
élevé dans une communauté hippie livrée
à elle-même bjork apprend à chanter
avant même de parler après 6 millions
d'albums vendus la chanteuse devient
actrice et décroche au passage le prix
d'interprétation féminine au festival de
cannes c'est un des traits majeurs de ma
personnalité vraiment le sacrifier me
battre tout donner pour une cause à
laquelle je crois est d'une certaine
manière c'est plus libérateur de le
faire pour un autre et que pour son
arrivée au cinéma
bjork offre sa musique son visage et sa
voix à selma
tu mets ça pis
tous y aller
à temps
jean
j'ai envie d'écrire toutes ces chansons
qui sont en moins depuis l'enfance
pourquoi pas d'autres musiques de films
et puis si je ne suis pas le but que la
vie m'a fixé la musique je serai puni je
ne parviendrai pas écrire mes chansons
je dois êtes pris donc maintenant la
musique danseurs in the dark est un
poème une explosion féerique venu du
froid voilà ça c'est l'album et le film
c'est pour bientôt dans quelques
semaines en france
je vous rappelle les principaux titres
de la critique nous avons développé dans
cette édition depuis 70 jours maintenant
nos amis jean-jacques le garrec irlande
madura sont détenus par les rebelles sur
l'île de judo avait cueilli à ses autres
tâches philippe un malaisien à notre
tâche américain sur une autre île tous
les otages seraient vivants selon les
autorités philippines
il serait avec les rebelles réfugiés
dans les monts volcanique de l'île de
jolo est ce pour faire face à
l'offensive militaire des trous de
manille
et puis de très nombreuses protestations
des restaurateurs et cuisinier français
contre la tva imposée aux métiers de
l'hôtellerie plus importante que celle
de ceux qui vendent des sandwichs la
météo dans quelques secondes présentée
par nathalie rihouet et puis après jour
après jour présenté par jean luc delarue
à 23h05 mots croisés avec chabot alain
duhamel
peut-on vivre avec moins de pétrole
débat autour des prix des carburants de
voitures propres comme invités y aura
jean claude gayssot daniel cohn bendit
louis schweitzer le dg de renault et
puis la ministre des transports isabelle
devant de belgique à 0 h 50 le journal
de la nuit présenté par dorothée
olliéric demain c'est au 50 dans les 4
vérités gérard morin recevra jean claude
gaudin le sénateur maire de marseille et
président de la communauté urbaine de
marseille à 13h bien sûr gg gérard holtz
et admirateurs bonsoir merci